vous avez été une des stars de Secret
Story après vous avez fait les anges
tout ça a pris des proportions énormes
vous avez commencé à en souffrir
énormément sans trop en parler et puis
un jour vous avez une accident de
voiture assez violent
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et Céline Dion en guerre contre sa
belle-fille comme vous le savez donc
elle a trois garçons les jumeaux et
d'inelson sont nés René Charles 22 ans
et malheureusement il ressemble un petit
peu à son père il a pris le mauvaise
chose de son père l'addition aux jeux
son père s'était des poker poker mais au
point même que Céline Dion devait
rembourser des ardoises gigantesques lui
c'est la machine poker mais il y passe
un temps fou et on avait dit
effectivement sa mère espérée qui soit
plutôt manager de sa tournée et il avait
dit non après il avait dit qu'il
sortirait un EP un disque un peu rap ça
n'a pas marché aujourd'hui bref il est
avec sa copine et il passe ses journées
dans un hôtel avec gaz à claquer du
pognon pendant que maman est dépressive
bon il joue énormément depuis quelques
années simplement c'est quelqu'un qui
était multimillionnaire avant même de
naître bon c'est comme les fils Beckham
c'est comme tout un tas de fils de
personnalités de célébrités ils sont
tous un peu allumés mais ils sont pleins
aux as donc là c'est juste de deux
jeunes gens plein aux astres qui
dépensent de l'argent elle elle est la
fille d'un tenancier enfin d'un patron
de casino
et qui a dit que ton jeu
c'est ce qu'on est dans le casino à
l'observer etc c'est un gars qui s'est
émancipé de sa maman il a refusé d'être
son manager il a la fibre musicale parce
qu'il a fait du rap et tout à l'heure tu
as été dur tu as dit fais rien du tout
de la vie unanime de tout un tas de
spécialistes sa musique est vraiment pas
mal du tout il s'appelle big d'ailleurs
il assure
vendu
qui compte hein que les ventes qui
comptent ah ça y est maintenant et la
qualité et la qualité oh là là
Marie Garet a gagné la saison 5 de
Secret Story une dizaine d'années
en plus d'avoir embauché au passage la
coquette SOP de 190.000 euros la jeune
femme est devenue instantanément célèbre
après avoir tourné dans plusieurs autres
émissions de téléréalité Marie est
aujourd'hui revenu à une vie normale en
reprenant son vrai métier celui
d'infirmière vous avez été une des stars
de Secret Story après vous avez fait les
anges tout ça a pris des proportions
énormes vous avez commencé en souffrir
énormément sans trop en parler et puis
un jour vous avez une excellente voiture
assez violent qui a fait qu'il y a dû
avoir de la chirurgie réparatrice
exactement les gens vous ont vu sur les
réseaux et vous ont insulté elle a fait
la chirurgie esthétique et là on a été
proches de la tentative de suicide déjà
je suis toujours reconnu dans la rue
sauf que avant
j'étais aduler aujourd'hui je me fais
insulter tous les noms
infirmière était les réalités ça ne va
pas ensemble tout simplement donc ça
vous avez des patients qui vous le
disent que vous arrivez parfois mais en
fait j'ai des patients qui ont changé
d'infirmière carrément parce qu'en fait
il faut toujours en prouver 10 fois plus
qu'une personne lambda retourner dans la
lumière plus jamais je suis encore
malheureusement dans la lumière mais
dans la mauvaise lumière
faut savoir que je rencontre des gens je
ne sais jamais si les gens sont là pour
moi pour ma notoriété ou parce qu'ils
pensent que j'ai de l'argent et je peux
vous poser une question assez étonnante
quand même si aujourd'hui vous voulez
vraiment essayer de faire en sorte que
plus personne vous reconnaisse dans la
rue et que la lumière vous a fait du mal
je suis très heureux de vous avoir sur
ce plateau mais il y a entre 6 millions
et 15 millions de personnes qui nous
regardent et qui vont forcément vous
reconnaître et remettre un euro dans la
machine dans la dans la ville où vous
habitez c'est parce que c'est important
d'en parler d'accord justement pour les
générations futures pour les filles qui
à l'heure actuelle rêvent de faire de la
télé-réalité faut savoir que ça colle à
la peau toute une vie
revient aujourd'hui et qui prennent des
des golds de commander des anciens et
des nouveaux des All Stars merci tu y
vas ou pas
[Musique]
du monde selon la science les critères
c'est le chirurgien plastique Julian Da
Silva qui est venu à ces résultats
publiés en janvier 2023 pour y parvenir
il a adapté aux êtres humains cette
équation mathématique à l'origine
utilisée par les architectes et les
artistes dans l'élaboration de
chef-d'oeuvre il y a l'écartement ici il
y a la taille des lèvres il y a plein de
choses et tout est calculé et selon lui
on peut avoir ce qu'on appelle le visage
parfait s'il y avait 100% il pourrait
vous refaire un visage parfait
mathématiquement bon pour moi perso je
trouve pas spécialement beau
[Musique]
mec parfait qu'est-ce qu'il a de
en posant entièrement nu pour un
magazine américain cette semaine pamelan
Anderson nous prouve qu'elle n'a rien
perdu de son goût pour la provoque et
pour le business
car cette semaine c'est également la
sortie événement de son autobiographie
Love et surtout de son documentaire sur
Netflix dans lesquelles l'actrice de 55
ans se met aussi à nu mais
émotionnellement cette fois-ci dans ce
film de 2h l'actrice d'Alerte à Malibu
revient entre autres sur son adolescence
très difficile au cours de laquelle elle
a été violée par un homme de 25 ans
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous vous
étiez attaché de presse bien sûr à
l'époque mais vraiment dans les années
en plus Alerte à Malibu au moment où ça
cartonnait à partir de février 97 je me
suis occupé de la sortie de son livre
elle était venue en France etc elle
était adorable d'ailleurs elle est
adorable dans la vie ah oui adorable
sympathique comme tout avec des sujets
et puis elle était dans son conte de fée
parce que c'est un conte de faible la
souverain expliqué quand elle est
repérée elle démarre sa carrière de
manière hasardeuse en 1988 elle a un
t-shirt avec une marque de bière et le
cadreur un des réalisateurs l'apprend au
milieu du public ouais dans un match de
basketball à Vancouver absolument et à
partir de là il la repère et il y a
tellement d'audience au moment où elle
est avec
fantastique et d'un seul coup finalement
la marque de bière langage et à tout de
suite à lire à faire les photos pour
Playboy appelle derrière
elle commence ses cours de Playboy à la
fête 14 + tous les hors-séries ça
représente à peu près 25 coups vous
savez c'est un jeu de rôle il y a une
composition parmi toutes les grandes
personnalités de la planète souvent
quand elles font des carrières comme ça
fulgurante avec un succès planétaire
d'abord il y a des hommes d'affaires
derrière et c'est un jeu de rôle elle
joue un personnage faut jamais l'oublier
donc
je crois pas je crois je crois pas du
tout qu'elle a plus d'argent du tout
bien sûr pourquoi pas mais tout ça c'est
écrit ces scénarisé ah bon mais bien sûr
sinon il y a rien dans le documentaire
si vous si vous expliquez
pendant 1h30 non mais vous savez il y a
toujours deux lectures sur ce genre de
documents
alors le fameux taux milique de son mari
à la fin il se battent ils se battent la
police lui va en prison il a pas le voir
ses enfants enfin c'est un peu compliqué
ces deux fils qui tournent maintenant et
elle dit que Tommy la dernière année de
Baywatch à Malibu c'était tellement
compliqué il venait en régie tout le
temps il était derrière la caméra il
regardait en permanence pour qui est
aucune scène ou à l'embrasse quelqu'un
d'autre sinon il Hurley cassé tout dans
les loges c'est aussi à cause de lui
qu'elle a arrêté bon bref c'était un
malade